we're trying to strengthen the way we
view the world and and take in as much
information as we can and see that
information for what it truly is not
what we want it to be well here we are
on the Sunday special with Joe Rogan
we're going to jump into the interview
in just a moment because this is awesome
but first I want to say thanks to our
sponsors over at movement so movement
they make these kinds of watches right
it's nice go by one movement is come far
from being crowdfunding kids working out
of a living room in the past year
they've not only introduced a bunch of
new watch collections for both men and
women but they've also expanded
sunglasses and bracelets for her
movement watches start at just 95 bucks
in a department store these are like
four or five hundred dollars movement
figured out by selling online they could
actually cut out the middleman retail
markup providing the best possible price
classic design quality construction
style minimalism get 15% off today with
free shipping and free returns just go
to MVM t.com slash shapiro see why the
movement keeps growing check out their
expanding collection get into MVM
t-dot-com slash apparel join the
movement and again look at it's nice
right I mean like you could use one as
well okay so here we are on the Sunday
special with Joe Rogan the granddaddy of
us all on the podcast space I mean this
dude made the podcast space the podcast
space and he's awesome also so thanks so
much for Sodom I think I did then I
think Adam Carolla did it well I'll have
to have you guys fight it out too so
I'll have to have to buddy but there's
no question that right now your
dominance in the space and it's an
amazing thing because you're really
gifted guy but you can you can sit there
for three hours with somebody and talk
about the most random topic and make it
really interesting so I need the
backstory so all of my listeners and and
people who are fans of mine might not
know your work as well might not know
kind of your story so how did you get to
be doing what you're doing right now
like give it give us the whole history
well with the podcasting it just started
out doing a video thing with just
Ustream we're just doing Q&A like people
would tweet questions we'd ask answer
questions just for fun I did it once and
I actually did it a couple of times
backstage in between shows years before
that there's a thing called Justin TV
which I'm not sure what that is now
became a new company but we would just
show backstage we'd have like a webcam
go
and would just play around and talk to
people and have fun and then we did the
one Q&A and I said alright I'm gonna do
it again next week we'll try to do it
regularly so I did it again the next
Monday and then it became a weekly thing
that we started uploading it to iTunes
and then we started getting guests and
then I said okay I gotta get out of my
house and do all these weirdos were
coming over my house like I'll just get
a studio somewhere so I got a studio and
then after the studio mic well the
studio is kind of little let's get a
bigger studio so then I got a bigger
studio and then now it's somehow or
another it's a business you've got a
monster studio you were telling me about
now that's just awesome it's and that's
pretty crazy indoor archery range and a
full gym and it's it's pretty nuts I've
totally gone wrong with this this studio
there's no question about it so what got
you all the way to the the podcasting I
mean like start from beginning from
childhood from birth like what what's
your whole back story well from high
school until I was 21 I was competing in
martial arts tournaments that was my
background I was a Taekwondo instructor
I taught at Boston University I competed
in all these different national
tournaments I traveled all around the
country most of my formative years were
spent traveling around the country
fighting in martial arts tournaments
that was basically all I did with my
entire day like I was obsessed from the
time I was 15 till I was 21 when I was
21 I started doing stand-up comedy and I
went frameshift
yeah well you know I was I was realizing
that fighting was really bad for your
brain I was getting a lot of headaches
and there's a lot of sparring like I was
getting into kickboxing I have three
kickboxing fights and and I was
realizing that this this is going to
definitely have a negative effect on my
consciousness there was no way around it
and the quality of my thoughts and the
way I think about things was always it's
one of the most important things to
guide you through life and I'm like I am
putting my my future brain in jeopardy
and I was seeing it around me from a
bunch of other people that were in the
gym that were professional fighters and
that were getting brain damage I was
essentially seeing them starting to slur
their words and I was seeing I was
seeing this effect and
I knew I had to get out somehow or
another and luckily one of my friends
who my friend Steve Graham I'm good
friends with to this day talked me into
doing stand-up comedy talked me into
going up in an open mic night when I was
21 it's amazing and you've been doing
that ever since when you're still doing
shows today right now yeah so you've got
the special it's on Netflix which is
awesome yeah I have one special son
that's well two of them that are on
Netflix now but then a new one that I
just filmed that'll be on Netflix in
September which is really so I want to
ask you actually a little bit about the
MMA stuff cuz you're still you still
cover MMA you're so big and em and they
obviously a big analyst over there what
do you do you think that there is I've
been wearing about this about the NFL
and I wonder if it also applies to MMA
do you think that there is always going
to be MMA there's always going to be NFL
boxing do you think these things are
always going to exist or do you think
that as a society we're gonna transition
away from those as people start to
become more concerned about brain injury
for example I've seen the NFL's ratings
declined because people seem to be
really worried about concussion levels
yeah I think in the recent future we're
going to have these things but I think
in the distant future were probably not
going to I think we're gonna move away
from them because of the damage that
they do because we're gonna understand
unless there's some radical new medical
technology that can regenerate brain
tissue to the point where you don't have
to worry about brain injuries which is
not outside the realm of possibility you
know I mean medical science what they're
doing with stem cells and exosomes and
all the different therapies that they're
using on people today who knows I mean
who knows what they're going to be able
to do fifty years from now but I think
it's entirely likely that until until
then until some radical new technology
comes on I think it's probably going to
be less in the last people that are
interested in having their kids sign up
to play football you're seeing that now
definitely have less and less people
interested in fighting since traumatic
brain injuries have been revealed to be
you know really prevalent in kids that
are involved in like football even at
like Pop Warner and high school levels
and in fighting I mean just from the
time a kid can hit hard you know like
you're in you know like one of the good
things about martial arts teaching kids
young is we teach them young they can't
really hurt each other yet so even when
they're hitting each other it's all very
light and they're
technique and movement before there's
real consequences and then as they get
older though now if you're sparring when
you're a teenager and you're sparring
when you're you know in your early 20s
you're absolutely giving yourself brain
damage it's just part of the package
that you have to just be able to figure
out okay when advice when have I
suffered enough when when am I getting
out and that is the big question for a
lot of fighters when do I jump off this
ride because it's so exciting
and what they're doing is such a
incredibly thrilling and glory filled
event you know when you're competing
against another person they lock you in
a cage and the way I describe fighting I
mean a lot of people like to think of it
as a barbaric thing I call it high-level
problem solving with dire physical
consciousness and that's really the best
way to describe it because you're trying
to do something to someone who's trying
to do something to you and genetics and
knowledge and technique and discipline
and drive and focus these are all
factors that are mixed up in this thing
and you're trying to figure out who's
gonna come out on top I mean I wonder if
maybe that's the reason that MMA is
gonna keep growing as the NFL declines
in honesty and marketing when you watch
MMA you're getting we're watching people
get the crap right watching people bleed
and your bones get broken
the NFL's been promising for years that
basically everyone's fine that it's all
just watching people hit pillows and
then you see them later and they can't
walk and they're falling apart and I
mean I do wonder if there is a certain
element of channeling just the human
driver to the male drive for aggression
in watching these kinds of sports
because I know a lot of genteel dudes
who love MMA specifically because
there's part of just the human psyche
that needs to watch people get their ass
kicked
yeah it's genetic it's it's definitely
in our corman it's what led people to
overcome being invaded by by you know
foreign villages that snuck in it in the
middle of the night yet to be able to
fight with your hand it will fall over
mates how people fought over territory
and property it's just a part of the
human experience and to to have it
boiled down into a martial art then it's
like you get all the satisfaction of
watching combat but at the end of it
people are friendly they hug you know
they shake hands they raise each other's
arms up the audience cheers and
and it's very thrilling and you know and
some could say it's actually cathartic
that it actually releases this desire
for aggression and violence yeah I think
there's a good case we made for that
especially because you do see that in
the animal kingdom you see chimpanzees
sparring with each other basically just
it for a show dominance and you
certainly see it among young boys I can
see it with my two-year-old now sure
like constantly just wants to fight the
four-year-old girl she wants to sit
there and be nice and play with her and
play with her toys and read and my
two-year-old boy wants to kick kick some
ass I mean he's hardcore and which gets
us a you know one of the topics that you
and I have talked about before which is
sort of these these gender differences
between male and female it as you've
been watching the last it's been
probably a year and a half since we last
talked what do you think of sort of the
the movement that's continued to pace to
get rid of these these gender
differences that you've been seeing in
society more broadly it's very strange
because it's science denialism
and the left is all about science until
it comes to gender and once it comes to
gender they don't want to hear about
studies they don't want to hear about
genetic differences between males and
females they don't want to hear about
preferences or or any studies that show
that people with higher testosterone
testosterone tend to go towards certain
activities people with lower ones tend
to go I don't want to hear about that
they they want this weird thing where
you're not even having the boy scouts
anymore
you just have the scouts like there's
this bizarre desire to eliminate gender
as even just even a variable so if we're
very weird and I don't I don't know why
I don't know where it's going I don't
know what's causing it I suspect it's
people that don't enjoy certain aspects
of male versus female competition or
male versus male competition and the way
that they feel like they could sort of
diminish that is to try to make the
whole subject seem like as if it's
fruitless and there's nothing there
let's leave it on there is no difference
so it's a it's a weird weird time when
it comes to a discussing gender a gender
all of a sudden which was something that
was just oh there's a boy there's a girl
I mean our whole life within the last
half a decade it's become this huge
the politically charged subject where
you what do you like I saw my my wife
was reading this thing that she had to
fill out today and she goes look at this
she goes it says what do I identify with
male or female she's not it's like state
your sex it used to be state your sex
now it's what do you identify with and
I'm like okay what percentage of the
people are we play caning with this yeah
like and it so bizarre it actually
has medical consequences so I know a lot
of doctors because it have said many
times my wife is a doctor and there are
cases now where doctors are walking into
a room and it says on the chart that
somebody is of a particular sex and
they're not of that sex because they're
writing the sex they perceived
themselves to be well it changes your
diagnosis you have a completely
different body so what you know I heard
a story about one patient who came in
and was having lower abdominal pain well
if you're a boy versus you're a girl
that's gonna make a pretty large
difference in to how that diagnosis goes
it's not at least a doctor know what sex
you're born with it's it's totally wild
and it's all this attempt to level I
think everything the attempt to just get
rid of natural differences between human
beings and pretend they don't exist like
we all want everybody to obviously have
equal rights and equal liberties but
that's not the same thing as saying that
everybody is gonna be equally strong in
a fighting ring what do you think is
causing all this I mean I I think what's
causing all of this is that there's a
deep desire right now in in a free
society to try and figure out why some
people succeed and some people fail and
we're never allowed to say that there
are natural issues at stake and in some
and I understand the resistance to based
on race right so for example you see a
lot of people who will say you can't
ever talk about racial differences in IQ
because that is going to lead to toward
this racist conclusion that your race
defines your IQ which is you know a
silly conclusion like there are racial
differences in IQ based on kind of group
statistics that has no relevance to the
particular individual standing in front
of you and so you saying this black guy
is stupid because he's black is racist
you saying there are group differences
in IQ because every study ever done is
showing group differences in IQ not even
based on racial groups necessarily based
on different groups generally between
between you know age groups there are
differences in IQ actually if you if you
show that at least from young age to to
like 12
if you mention any of these things then
you're overriding the idea
a tabula rasa human being who can be
created in whatever image you want like
what people really want is to correct
the cosmic imbalances as Thomas Olsen's
I know what do you think is behind it I
think that I think you're hitting the
nail on the head and I I think there's a
tremendous amount of white guilt
involved in it as well
I mean because basically what the IQ
tests are showing when they do study
differences in IQ and and races you're
showing the rise of the superiority of
the Asian race I mean Asians dominate
those things and everybody is so just
like well that's that's let's not talk
about that let's talk about white and
black because that's more convenient and
it's easier and they could find a victim
and they could find a perpetrator and
what you're also seeing like there's a
lot of Asian groups that are furious
because they're getting discriminated
against about getting into colleges and
universities they have higher standards
because they have such a high percentage
of Asians that are getting into the
universities and it's it's very strange
because they're not vocal about it and
they're not they're not publicizing it
and they're not screaming racism in the
streets but they're the victims of it
they actually the victims of hard work
and success and excellent genetics right
well there's no question and the
differences in culture are really the
place where we should be putting most of
our focus because when it comes to you
know natural imbalances there's only so
much that you can do right I'm not gonna
be fighting you in a ring anytime soon
said just get destroyed but the same
when it comes to cultural differences
that's the stuff that we can correct for
and instead of doing now what we tend to
do is we tend to pretend that the
cultural differences are not brought
about by immediate decision-making by
parents or by immediate communities it's
it's something out there right it's it's
racism in the ether or it's
discrimination writ large it's something
it's something out there we can't we
can't put our heads around it exactly
but something that's making us
imbalanced and so the way to fix that is
by getting rid of all imbalances that we
see and so if there's an imbalance
between men and women we'll just pretend
that that doesn't exist anymore and that
it must have been caused by something
that we can't quite control yeah it's
definitely not an objective way of
approaching the issue I think there's a
host of different factors that play into
every community right there's the the
echoes of the poor behavior of the
people that live there before you all
the consequences of other people's
actions that have affected all the
people around you
people going to jail people that have
experienced racism people that have
experienced poor treatment by law
enforcement massive distrust around you
very difficult to excel in those
environments you're constantly like
running away from gangs and headed home
I don't think we should hold those
people up to the same standards as we
should people to grow up in very safe
middle-class communities where they
don't have to worry about all this stuff
I think there's a bunch of different
factors and everybody's looking for ones
only the one factor that appeals to
their ideology yeah and that's a real
problem
it's a problem also anytime you mention
IQ everybody goes nuts yes immediately
they suggest that what you're saying is
is racist and the truth is that whatever
IQ differentials there are it's unclear
how much is explained by genetics and
how much is explained by environment but
some is clearly explained by genetics
and some is clearly explained by
environment as soon as you say that
everybody suggests that you are
operating in a racist space so it's as
you say when it comes to data like this
happened with Sam Harris when he was
being interviewed by Ezra Klein as a
reclined just went after him for
suggesting that science is science well
science is still science even if you
don't like the science and Jim's like
the same thing should apply when it
comes to biological differences in a
second I want to ask you about the
comedy world because that's obviously
the other area in which you in which you
exist but first I want to say thanks to
our sponsors over a policy genius so
over 80% of people think life insurance
costs double what it actually costs not
only that 100 percent of people think
buying life insurance is a giant pain in
the butt well here's the truth you're
gonna die okay just sorry to break it to
you you're gonna die and when you do you
can either leave your family poor or
they can have some life insurance on you
now healthy 35 year olds can get half a
million bucks in coverage for less than
30 bucks a month and getting life
insurance doesn't have to be complicated
because of policy genius so policy
genius has helped over 4 million people
shop for insurance they've placed twenty
billion dollars in coverage if you've
been thinking about getting life
insurance go over to policy genius check
it out it's the easy way to compare top
insurers find the best policy for you
save time money hassle and it's free so
policy genius comparing life insurance
doesn't need to be a pain in the neck
and again don't die and leave your
family poor just don't be an idiot go to
policy genius and check it out okay so
do I want to ask you about about the
comedic imbalance so I know that later
this week you're scheduled to have on
Roseanne we're pre taping this a little
bit so your schedule they have on
Roseanne what do you make of the
Roseanne Fonz do you think that ABC was
right - it's a dumper show after after
her bizarre tweet about Valerie Jarrett
what's interesting is just saying that
she was gonna be on my podcast she said
it and then I got all these tweets they
were saying boycott Joe Rogan the UFC
should fire me for having this racist on
my podcast like no I'm gonna have a
conversation with one of the greatest
stand-up comedians of all time a person
who I deeply respect who I think is
mentally ill she is on a host of
different medications she's taking
ambien and drinking she was pushed to
the brink of exhaustion doing that
television show and she's made some very
poor choices with some of the things
that she said she would be the first to
tell you that and I don't think that you
I don't think you could get an
understanding of her from a tweet or
from you know a one sentence description
of what she did I think you need to hear
her and hear her talk she's gonna be the
first person tell you she's crazy and
she is she's she's essentially at least
functionally mentally ill you know but
it's also why she's such a brilliant
comedian and she's always been what you
would call a stirrer you know if people
don't remember like when she used to
when she sung the national anthem a
rabbit crotch and spit on the ground and
everybody went crazy
that's Roseanne you know and I think
people wanted to turn her into this
lovable mother there's this like thing
that people do when life gets weird
which is like where it's at right now
where they want to look back to the past
where things just made sense can't we
just bring back the Roseanne of old look
John Goodman's there - this is amazing
everything was safe when I was a kid and
that's what they're trying to do and
they don't realize like she's tweeting
crazy about someone looking like
they're from Planet of the Apes which by
the way she said she didn't even know
that that woman was black and she's just
telling this to me on the phone she goes
she goes I'm not stupid do you think I
would say that about a black but she was
I thought she was Jewish she was look at
her she looks like my relatives it's
what she said to me on the phone I
believe her I believe she makes some
terrible choices I mean she was someone
sent me some stuff this morning like
look what this crazy she's tweeting I
was something about George Soros as soon
as I read Soros I just
done I put the phone down and walk away
because it's all like lizard people and
alex jones and interdimensional child
molesters george soros is patrolling the
marijuana and i can't i'm out that's
like the number george soros to me is my
like my mother line that i will not
press my dmz of like conspiracy theories
as soon as you get into soros is soros
is hiring those women's march people
they don't even want to be there they're
all being paid like how much money is
this guy have there's a million people
in every city what's he paying them a
dollar even if you paid him a dollar
that's a significant amount of money and
they're not gonna do that for a dollar
you're gonna have to pay them a lot of
money like you sure they're being paid
but it's like that soros guy as soon as
you start tweeting and talking about
soros like my brain just checks out is
our big problem with with rosianna a lot
of celebrities the attempt to mainstream
them is normal human beings and you see
this from both sides i i think to a
certain extent you saw the republicans
did this with kid rock where suddenly
kid rock is gonna run for senate
definitely could've won and you see
kanye west they're doing the same thing
now or in kanye west's is a grand
expositor of the constitution of the
united states and listen i'm happy for
anybody to think for themselves of
Chania wants to talk about voting
republican i'm replicant i'm happy with
that that's fine but to pretend that
entertainers i mean i've lived after my
entire life dependent entertainers and
show people aren't a bunch of crazy
people is just nuts thank you they're
like the level of nuttiness in this town
is so high and yet the halo effect that
we have about celebrities is that well
if they're famous and i see them on TV
that must mean that they're smart in
real life no no it's a biological trick
and what it is is when you evolved when
when all of us lived thousands of years
ago we look to the most successful
member of the tribe the one who was
older the one that everybody revered he
was the best hunter he was the smartest
warrior he was the one with the scars in
his face that had survived battle and he
could relay to you the lessons of a life
well-lived this is what I learned this
plants poisonous that snake oak Illya
and all of this stuff now gets relayed
to someone who's on a giant screen now
we see Brad Pitt his head is twenty feet
tall there's music
when he talks his lines are all
carefully constructed by a team of
writers and we get sucked into it like
he's a real hero and we do that for
anybody that gets attention whether it's
Kim Kardashian or Taylor Swift we we see
these people and millions of people are
paying attention to them so we assume
that there's some quality behind
everything that they're saying there's
something special about them but there's
not it's a biological trick that is it's
perpetrated through and that it's not by
a grand conspiracy but through media
through being able to put them on a
YouTube screen or on a television or a
laptop or wherever you're digesting it
and the knowledge that when you're
watching a clip where Kanye West's talk
about running for president and you look
down the number and it says oh my god 24
million people have watched this and
there's 15,000 thumbs up what the and
this is this is the world that we're
living in today so you you you say well
it must be God Kanye is gonna win Kanye
is gonna win and this is exactly how
Donald Trump got into office we have a
popularity contest to see who becomes
president and we have the very first
ever popular person enter a popularity
contest a guy who is a longtime media
personality he knew very well how to
manipulate that how he was charismatic
he's a old speaker he's not afraid to
piss people off he knows he has a bunch
of people that like what he has to say
and he could rile them up and this is
what's strange about taking the word of
celebrities over the word of professors
or of public intellectuals or of people
that have actually carefully considered
all these things that are discussing and
have about a lot of information and
they're basing these conclusions and
these statements on a long history of
research and this is not what you're
gonna get from Kanye he's a guy who
doesn't even read he doesn't read and
he's our guy he uses your incorrectly
all the time he's the wrong you're like
like Piers Morgan I mean we both have
our thoughts on Piers Morgan but one of
the things he wrote like he corrected
him and he's like no you're never going
to be President
you know he shouldn't read that because
that's exactly what Barack Obama said
about President
give me your take on last time I talked
to you was before the election I think
yeah so what so what what's your take on
President Donald Trump since we now have
a year and a half of the Donald Trump in
office everyone sucks at that job
Hillary would have sucked at that job
too it would have been a disaster
I think her health would have failed I
don't think she would have made any
difference in the world
I don't think he's gonna make any
difference in the world for the positive
I think what we need is a Council of
wise people and I think that this idea
of one alpha chimp that runs the whole
thing based on a popularity contest is
crazy I think it's a terrible idea I
think it would it was a good idea in
1776 it's a terrible idea in 2018 I just
don't think it works and I think you
should be able to vote online I
absolutely think you should be able to
vote online if you could do your taxes
online if you could Bank online and do
all the different things that people do
online you should be very easy to
register and it you'd get a much more
balanced percentage of the population
than we do now it would be by having
these barriers like you got to go to a
physical location you got to sign up
long in advance they're preventing
certain people from voting whether
that's good or bad is up for debate but
I think if you want to get a real
understanding of how all growing adults
in this country feel about certain
issues they should be able to vote
online and having one person run the
whole thing like a president and be able
to do some of the things that Trump has
done like strip the EPA of a lot of its
power you know give the thumbs up to
offshore drilling a lot of things that
scare this out of people because there's
real consequences for many generations
in advance forget about the the the what
he's doing with the financial
institutions and how he's opening up
doors for businesses that's debatable
good or bad you know whether it's good
for the economy is it is it bad for the
middle class is it bad I don't these are
good questions but I think what's good
about having someone who is widely
regarded as being incompetent as
president is that it's entirely possible
that we might come to a point where we
have to rethink the way we run and
structure
so I'm actually more encouraged by his
presidency than you are I think one of
the reasons is because the checks and
balances worked so I think one last we
talks we said you know is Trumpkin and
just run roughshod over the entire
system of government and the reality is
that no he's done some stuff at the
executive level but the stuff that he's
done at the executive level should never
have been at the executive level anyway
it should've been all legislature stuff
so when you talk about what he's done
with the EPA my feeling is that we
should have a Congress that makes the
actual law on the environment we
shouldn't have a group of unelected
bureaucrats who make the actual law in
the environment we can't get rid of if
we don't like it's good point and so
having them write these broad laws that
are then delegated to Donald Trump's
friends over in the in the executive or
Barack Obama's friends over the
executive so then interpret and change
into all the stuff with takes power out
of the hands of the human beings who are
actually elected to do it and who we can
throw out I can't throw out the EPA
Administrator so it's the one thing
that's been good about Trump is and this
is the other one I've made to people who
don't like President Trump is you don't
like President Trump totally fine I
didn't like President Obama thought it
was garbage here's a great idea how
about none of these people have a lot of
power how about we just evolve a lot of
the power all the way back to the local
level and to the states and I understand
their environmental issues where they
cross boundaries they cross state lines
for example you're gonna have to have
some federal environmental regulations
but a lot of this stuff can be done at
the local level whether you're talking
about financial institutions or whether
you're talking about environmental stuff
most environmental damage is being done
at the local level it's not being done
across state lines so it's it's I've
been encouraged by the fact that the the
system is more durable than I thought it
was I think that the founders were smart
enough to build in a bunch of checks and
balances that the president as much as
we tend to think of him as the guy who
runs everything I mean let's be real
about this president Trump is sitting on
the second floor of the Oh of the White
House he doesn't in the Oval right he's
in the second floor of the White House
watching Shark Week and everybody
downstairs is actually doing a lot of
the work try and put the other policy
with Congress some of it gets done some
of it doesn't and even a lot of those
people are spending a lot of their time
online trying to figure out how kim
kardashian convert visitors i guess
really is for your for your money do you
want to see a more active government or
a less active government because I'm
kind of happy with the gridlock I'll be
honest with you I kind of like the fact
the government doing anything there's
definitely some pros to that I think it
would be better if we had a more
competent system and I agree with you
that the checks and balances have
we've shown that he can't just throw
everything out and and just run Trump
mania all across the country I think
there's definitely some some positive to
that gridlock so it's okay so what
changes would you make to the system
because you talk about the system being
being a process you talked about online
voting do you mean online voting direct
on issues or you mean online voting for
representatives all the above okay so
you like the referendum system in
California I think if you have opinions
on things I mean first of all this is
really unpopular I think you should have
to show that you have an understanding
of what you're voting on you should
probably have I'm fine with it yeah if
you want to get rid of the idea
requirements and retain the actual you
need to know what you're talking about
the environment I think I could I think
you should take a test and if you
understand what what the consequences of
your decision are you understand what
what is being voted on then you can vote
on it but if you just read if you just
go check yes check no just do it
haphazard just because you're a crazy
person and you happen to be 18 I think
that's pretty ridiculous and but to have
a test and have someone say well you
have to be you have to be required to
understand have a rudimentary
understanding of what you're talking
about
in order to make an opinion that could
literally affect 300 million people a
lot of people would say that's bad
because then what about are you are you
saying that people have to have a
certain intelligence level in order to
vote is this like you did are you at the
door of eugenics like what do you where
you going with this well I think it's
not a bad idea to say that if you're
gonna vote on really important issues
like whatever those issues are whether
it's funding the military or abortion or
whatever it is you should have an
understanding of the subject I don't
think that's unreasonable but people
don't want any extra work and they they
want things to be very very convenient
no one that virtually signaling also
being able to vote have voting right now
is just virtue signaling like
demonstrates the public at large to
people at large what this vote means to
you so is Hillary Clinton campaigning on
if you vote for me you'll show that you
voted for a woman and if you vote for
Barack Obama you've shown that you vote
for a black guy if you're voting for
Donald Trump you're sticking a middle
finger to the system itself symbolic
voting very little of it seems
about like what's this guy actually
gonna do 1c there yeah and that's that's
a that's a serious problem okay so I
wanted to I want to turn to kind of the
political correctness that how do you do
your job in a politically correct
universe but first I want to say thanks
to our sponsors over at Lending Club so
sometimes people need a helping hand
whether it's unexpected repairs or
medical expenses or credit card debt
sometimes a little money makes a big
difference you can get that at Lending
Club com Lending Club gives you access
to low rates on loans of up to 40 grand
for virtually any purpose you take
control of your debt finance a major
purchase finally make those home
improvements and it's easier than going
to a bank and it's lower rate than a
higher interest credit card they're not
gonna pay back in time just go to
Lending Club com enter how much money
you need and see if you're approved in
minutes and then you can pick the offer
that's right for you the money can be in
your account in just a matter of days
it's that simple more than 10 years
Lending Club has helped millions of
people with over thirty 1 billion bucks
in loan take charge of your finances
today Lending Club com go to Lending
Club comm slash been guest because I
have a guest to check your rate for free
it's not gonna impact your credit score
that's Lending Club comm slash been
guest Lending Club comm slash been guest
all loans made by web bank member FDIC
Equal Housing lender ok so you make
jokes for a living ready make lots of
jokes for living how you gonna survive
in this environment making jokes for a
living just piss people off I mean
there's you're gonna always have people
you have more people upset with you and
there's more righteous indignation I
think than I've ever seen in comedy I've
had more people furious at me for what
are clearly jokes then ever at any other
time in my career and this is the
hardest thing right cuz you make it
something that's clearly a joke and then
somebody writes down the transcript of
the joke and now you have to explain the
joke right that immediately kills it cuz
as soon as you explain a joke it's no
longer a joke so if you make a joke
that's politically incorrect and then
they write it down and everybody who
heard you at the time knows that you
were making a joke if they write it down
then you have to explain it
automatically exited the realm of jokes
and so now you're trying to explain the
statement as like as as true or decent
right that's not the point of the joke
in the first place yes exactly and you
look you missed the context you missed
the the way was delivered you missed the
tone you miss everything but what
they're doing is they're just trying to
find targets and I think that's one of
the things that's happening with Roseann
that's one of the things that's
happening whenever anybody screws up in
the media a you you you just get these
people that they want a target it's a
game and
game is take someone down the game is
call someone out take someone down shame
them you know get get the Twitter mob
and the Facebook mob get him after him
let's go as Goods move let's start a
hashtag let's attack Morgan Freeman I
heard he told a joke you know I mean
this is like me did you read the the
woman's account from CNN with a with a
Carey interview with Morgan Freeman I
think we covered it but I can't remember
it he was playing God in a movie you
know he's played God in a movie and she
asked him if you had magic power what
would you do with it and he said you
wouldn't have a stitch of clothes on
that was the joke knows it and and she
was like god you messed with the wrong
girls and I'm number 17 at all these
girls that have come after he's like wow
you know like he was on the spot he's
being interviewed
he's on a red carpet he tries to crack a
joke about you being naked like is this
really the worst thing that's ever
happened to you is this really this or
is it just a joke and when I'm looking
at it even in text I find it to be silly
but just a joke is dying obviously just
a joke is still just a joke it's just a
joke well I think there is that backlash
happening it's one of the reasons why
you've become incredibly popular because
you just don't care right I mean well
that's I feel like if you have you money
and you don't save you then who's going
to who's going to like I'm a good person
I'm a nice guy I pay my taxes I I have a
bunch of great friends and loved ones
your kids I have kids I try to be nice
to people that's what I try to do but if
I see something that's ridiculous and I
make fun of it and people get mad at me
for that
that's on you well that's on you this is
why you eat so there's a picture of you
along with the rest of the intellectual
dark web in this big New York Times
speech by Barry Weiss I know were you
standing a bush or something like for
some reason everybody was in foliage
taking the taking these pictures so what
do you make of the whole intellectual
dark web contingent and there's been
this now huge backlash by a lot of folks
particularly on the left saying what's
up with this intellectual dark web is
just a bunch of unacceptable deplorable
people talking with each other and they
don't have anything to say what do you
make of the whole phenomenon well the
name is all Eric right Eric why instead
yeah yeah Eric Eric is
and he loves like all the
cloak-and-dagger and all the all the
hidden the just the name of it
intellectual dark web it's like he
concocted that so I was it Eric is he's
brilliant I love him I love his loves
and I have ever met because and I can't
understand half of what he's saying yeah
he's he's he's a very intense guy but he
loves all this stuff he gets a kick out
of it and I think there's a certain
amount of silliness in calling it the
intellectual dark web when you and I are
essentially in some sort of a super
group would a win or a super friend yeah
and what I felt was fascinating was that
a lot of people were trying to label us
as like deplorable conservatives and
like the one I are saying this is a
group of renegade conservative so I'm
pretty liberal like pretty liberal
across the board if you want to talk to
me about gay marriage you want to talk
to me about gay rights women's rights
like drugs you go drugs you go down the
line you universal health care universal
basic income I mean I'm pretty liberal
like it's it's but it doesn't fit the
narrative if I look like a trump
supporter right so like it this is a
white buffer well yeah yeah I'm a white
bald guy works out too much there's
there's a lot of you know there's a lot
there's a lot of need to label someone
into an easily dismissable category and
that that category is conservative like
ruthless nasty mean non and a person is
not kind and not not you're not a person
who's caring about other people you're a
conservative or a mean bully mean mean
mad white man as was his name that said
that to jordan peterson and the monk
debates Michael Dyson I think is so
Michael Eric Dyson yes yes that's all
Eric Tyson yeah they called Jordan
Peterson a mean mad white man Oh mad me
one of those yeah but it's uh there's
there's this need to cry on Hirsi Ali
and Christina Hoff Sommers and half the
people who are who are members of the
members of the club what exactly Dave
Rubin is gay
hilarious really like bizarrely diverse
group I mean really ideologically
diverse too because it's a bunch of
people like Brett Weinstein who's a
member of the of our secret our secret
group he's a socialist he backed Bernie
Sanders in the last elections yeah uh so
what do you think generated I wasn't
just the political correctness the
insanity yeah hard left it threw
everybody out dishonesty its dishonesty
it's the same thing that led to what
happened with Brett Weinstein at
Evergreen when they had this day of
absence where they wanted all white
people to stay home he's like hey this
is racist like you're your cat you're
you're absolutely targeting people based
on their race and saying you're not
welcome here this is a day instead of it
being a day of absence where people of
color stayed home voluntarily and
weren't chastised if they didn't instead
of that it was no white people have to
go away and if you don't you were a
racist and this is what happened with
Brett and it's a terrifying story and
when I interviewed him on my podcast it
was before he had left evergreen he was
still employed there and he was talking
to me about mobs that were wandering the
parking lot with baseball bats and they
were looking for him and it was
terrifying he had to get here to take
his family out of the state and who is
this is this are these Nazis are these
the KKK are these these right-wing thugs
no they're extreme progressives with
pink hair who are you know non-binary
sexually like it's very bizarre and
there's a lack of reality that you you
have to adhere to this narrative and if
you're not adhering to this narrative
then you are some horrific person who is
a product of the past and you're part of
the patriarchy and it's not an honest
discussion these if you if you see all
the people that are involved in this you
know air quotes intellectual darkweb the
one thing they have in common the all of
them are going what in the is everybody
talking about like what is this what's
happening here like why are we
pretending that men and women aren't
different things why are why are we
pretending that to tell people that you
have to
stay home because you're white it's
racist that is absolutely racist by
definition that's what racism is you're
discriminating against someone based on
the race
not based on their character or their
their job position or anything else
you're just just white people totally
agree I mean I think that the concepts
that seem to have United this group of
people who again are all over the place
on everything from religion to freewill
to politics is one we all like data and
we're interested in data so if you
presents us with data we're all happy to
take a look at it and maybe change our
opinions based on the new data that
you're presenting yes that's very
important and to that we're willing to
have conversations about those data
without regard for the political
niceties yes and then and three that
we're all I think big into the idea of
treating people as individuals that if
you're gonna treat me as a member of a
group I'm really not interested in
talking to you and I'm not interested in
being labeled as a member of a group
either yeah so we're a group of people
who don't like groups basically yes
hilarious a group of people who don't
like groups but we're also very friendly
and kind and I'm sure you and I disagree
on a bunch of things but we agree on a
lot of things as well but what I like
about you is you're a very reasonable
intelligent person that is you you're a
very polite person the way you talk to
people is very polite I think that's
something that's literally part of my
reputation me being polite but you are
my person you're a very kind polite
person and I think that this there's
something missing with this this idea
idea war that people are engaged in
where they want to demonize people to
disagree with them instead of just
sitting down and talking with them and
saying well why do you think this okay
let me let me try to look at it from
your perspective and this is why I
disagree and have a polite exchange of
ideas instead everyone's fighting for
their life as if you know whether or not
trans people can use the girls room is
gonna change the course of history it's
strange it's strange like battlegrounds
the lines that people are drawing in the
sand and and if you're on the other side
you're the enemy and you need to be shut
down and stopped it's it's there it's a
very weird time level anger is really
really troubling me and that's something
that I do feel like is kind of new so
I've spoken on college campuses for a
long time because I'm 34 now but I
started doing this stuff when I was 17
or 18 years old now speaking
campuses when I was 20 and I never had
to bring security with me to any of
these college campuses ever until the
last three years the last three years I
now have to have at least a two-man
security team at every college campus
and usually it's more than that based on
what the police are telling us about
reports in advance now half the time
nothing materializes but a few times
things have materialized and it's been
trouble and that that sometimes happens
where do you think this level of anger
is coming from because it appears to me
that that's what's new like these
political divides have always existed
these political divides between right
and left or political divides between
people who are more interested in
collective solutions versus individual
solutions why do you think people are so
pissed all the time and they're just you
can feel it in the air like the the
eagerness to stomp on somebody's face
he's really strong that's why when the
Roseanne thing happens it can't just be
like what you're saying where okay she's
a mentally ill person maybe you have to
take the show off the air maybe that's
the proper response but she might
actually have a problem here she she
certainly does well I think it's coming
from his toxic tribalism that's what I
think
I think people they are on a team they
want their team to win and they want
their team to win by any means necessary
and there they feel disenfranchised
because we have a president you know
Donald Trump I mean he is who he is
and he stands for a lot of things that
they find abhorrent and you you have a
lot of people now that are calling
themselves antifa and they're there by
literally by their own actions acting in
a fascist manner and they're calling
themselves anti-fascist and they're
putting bandanas in their face they're
hitting people with bike locks and
they're engaged in violence and the the
left is using violence as a means to
solve these differences that we have in
ideas and opinions they're shutting
people down like christina hoff sommers
just yelling out at her a woman who's
her whole life has been a feminist her
whole life and she calls herself a
factual feminist because she wants women
who are empowered and who are
intelligent to be held accountable for
their the actual facts behind what
they're saying and you know to discuss
this to empower people with reality and
by doing that she's become an enemy I
mean it's very strange to watch her get
shouted down by other feminists that
they
that she's the wrong kind of feminist
it's it's really bizarre but the anger
in the vitriol and the the violence
that's attached to it is something
that's completely new and was always
associated with right-wing thuggish mobs
it was always associated with hate
groups like the KKK or something
something along those lines you know the
neo-nazis but you're seeing this level
of violence from from the left now these
weird like university professors in
these dorky people that are saying burn
this mother down and and people were
cheering the streets and white people
are the problem and and there's so many
people that are tenured professors that
are getting away with saying like
ridiculous crazy and calling out for
violence and it's completely
irresponsible and it's it's it's foolish
it feels weird too because back in the
1960s at least there was something to
fight over at least back in the 1960s if
you were gay you said okay I don't have
my rights there's something to fight
over or your black and say I don't have
my rights true there's something to
fight over or you're female and you say
well feminism hasn't hasn't done what
needs to do yet there's something to
fight for
but right now country's pretty good like
thinking things are pretty good for the
vast majority of people in this country
put aside the economics for a second
because people always fail or rise in
economics it just happens but in some of
that is natural and some of that is
stuff that's fixable but one thing that
is certainly true is that the notion of
a governmental invasion of rights
against any of these groups this is not
something that is commonly happening
it's not that the government is cracking
down on black people or Hispanic people
or at this point even gay people and yet
there's this level of anger that feels
like riots in the 1960s I want to talk a
little bit more about that in just a
second first one makes money so first
we're gonna say thanks to our sponsors
over at stamps.com so these days you can
get practically everything on demand our
podcasts you can listen whatever you
want obviously when it's convenient for
you so why are you still going over to
the post office to mail letters and
packages when you can get postage on to
man with stamps calm with stamps calm
you can access all the amazing services
of the post office right from your desk
24/7 when it's convenient for you you
don't have to get in the car and waste
gas money buy and print official US
postage for any letter any package using
your own computer and printer and the
mail carrier just picks it up click
print mail you're done it could not be
easier we use it here at the Daily wire
offices we use it at the Shapiro
household as well in Shapiro scan right
now use been guests for this special
offer its promo
been guest you get up to 55 bucks free
postage a digital scale and a four week
trial go to stamps calm before you do
anything else click on the radio
microphone at the top of the homepage
type in that promo code been guessed
that stamps calm enter that promo code
been guessing to get that special deal
all right so we're talking about sort of
the levels of chaos and I have a theory
so might the L laid out for you so my
theory and I don't know where you stand
religiously are you agnostic atheist
religious more agnostic than anything I
grew up Catholic and I abandoned it when
I was a young boy I went to Catholic
school and that cured me so here's my
theory my theory is that everybody who's
broken down to tribalism because it used
to be that we were a larger tribe
meaning that the way that you the way
that you defeat local tribalism is by
creating a larger tribe that everybody
feels a kinship to and a membership to
so in the United States you had people
who've had tribal kinship to state
governments and then after the Civil War
that basically went away because the
federal government stepped in and
stopped slavery through through war
making power and then people felt a
general kinship to the federal
government you were American now he
wasn't that you were Californian or
you're a Texan you were now American and
the same thing goes back to biblical
times where you have you know all of
these various tribes you had the tribe
of manasseh and the tribe and the tribe
of the fryin and but they're the Jews
right there there's a bigger tribe that
eats them and it used to be that the
tribe for America was called America
right and that tribe was was bonded by a
certain set of Creole values values of
individual rights values of personal
virtue that these things had to be
combined you had to be a good person to
your neighbors but at the same time the
government had no right to come in and
take your stuff and force you to be a
nicer person
so you're the idea was that you
voluntarily were going to be a nicer
person to your neighbors because you
thought that was the right thing to do
but it wasn't the government's job to
come in and force you to be nicer to
your neighbors because that would be
fistic and overbearing and tyrannical
and that's gone away because people
don't feel like they have to be nice to
their neighbors they and I think part of
that has to be connected with lack of
communal institutions that you know I'm
not saying everybody has to go to church
but people who are in churches tend to
get along better with each other in the
church than people who are outside the
church and people inside the church
doesn't mean that you got to pick a
church but it doesn't mean that we have
to have some sort of communal
institutions and right now we are
savagely tearing apart each of our
communal institutions up to and
including things like the
fell or suddenly things were we would
bond over that like Super Bowl Sunday
was a bonding time for the country and
now we can't even bond over that we
can't find over anything right now
because all of these credo values have
been dissipated by our own personal
malevolence toward each other I think
that's a great point I think it's a
great point too about the benefit of
religion is that you do have these ideas
and values that are shared amongst this
community and group and when you are an
atheist or an agnostic I mean you don't
really have that group other than like
what you're what you're getting from a
lot of atheists you get this really
hardcore progressive ideology that is in
many ways like a religion and I think
there's there's probably some real merit
to what you're saying and the Robert
Putnam had makes this point in in his
book Bowling Alone he talks about the
this this new fascination with diversity
and the diversity is our strength and
this this whole line and he was a big
believer in this Robert Putnam the this
professor of sociology is big lefty and
and he says that that diversity was our
strength was his guiding kind of notion
and then he did the research into it
what he found is that as diversity of a
census tract increases the only thing
that he found that increase our protest
marches and tv-watching that's the only
thing that actually increases in a
particular area based on ethnic
diversity he said the only area where he
could see that ethnic diversity actually
made things better was in the context of
a broader group so in the Army for
example then ethnic diversity is great
because then you get a bunch of people
who are fighting for the same purpose
and the guy next to use your brother
doesn't matter if he's black or white
you see this with people who you talk to
her in the military all the time when
they talk about people of different
races in the military
this is usually the way they talk about
people of different races in the
military which is very different than
the way people talk about race in the
United States more broadly said you also
see this in churches but communal
institutions have have declined so
markedly that the only way I think that
we're gonna have be able to have a
system where we can all live with each
other is to reestablish some sort of
some form of communal talking with each
other even if it's just forums like this
one where we're talking with each other
and you know we if we did this live we'd
get thousands people to show up just to
hear us talk to each other even those
sort of communal institutions need to
exist otherwise we're going to
completely polarize mean I think it's
one of the dangers of the anti I love
the internet I've been living on the
Internet you make your living on the
internet but one of the dangers of the
Internet is that it's all personal to
you you don't actually have to go out
and be with other human beings
I hide behind the screen and tweet nasty
things at each other yeah you also can
find this group of like-minded people
and you share an echo chamber that's
it's another real issue for confirmation
bias I think what you're saying makes a
lot of sense and I think that we do need
we do need community you know and I
think the more people like you and like
Sam Harris and Eric and Brett Weinstein
people who are open-minded people who
are willing to discuss things politely
with people and not shove their ideology
down other people's throats the more we
exchange information with each other the
more this idea of being able to
communicate like this it becomes popular
and I think there's real benefit in that
I think there's real benefit in these
kind of podcasts style discussions
because of that because you can sit down
with it with a person that maybe doesn't
share the same opinions with you and you
can talk things out and maybe disagree
maybe argue but be polite to each other
and realize that a lot of these ideas
that we have we we have these
predetermined notions of the way we
think things should be and if you don't
fit with my predetermined notions then
there's no something wrong with you it's
never just examining these notions and
finding out where these ideas coming
from and why am I so married to them and
what is the solution to make everybody
comfortable is there a solution Kenny
and can we stop demonizing people that
disagree with us I think that the
principle that I think also unites every
and this is why everybody's getting
labeled conservative really yes because
everybody in that we've been talking
about here in the end actually does
believe in personal responsibility yeah
please and taking responsibility for
your own actions and you can be on the
left and still believe in taking
responsibility for your own actions but
it seems like so much of the left has
dumped out of that and you're seeing
that increasingly on the right - I think
that a lot of President Trump's appeal
during the during the actual election
cycle is him saying I'm gonna come in
and solve all your problems and my own
expense of your own damn problems I
think the only way your life is going to
get better is if you solve your own
problems because there are very few
people who had their problems solved for
them who actually are able to have a
successful life in the aftermath of
having all the problems solved for them
ya know that's a very good point yeah
you know why are we all considered
conservatives I mean Jordan Peterson is
an interesting example too because as
much
he calls himself a classic liberal you
know people have a hard time deciphering
what that is they don't even bother
looking it up and he is more so than I
think anybody in that Cole group is
getting attacked he's getting destroyed
right now his words are getting taken
out of context his positions are getting
distorted even in debates that during
the month yeah and they Kathy Newman
well that was my goodness that was
amazing did you read the New York Times
profile on Jordan I read on a little bit
of it but it was a hit month that that
piece was so astonishing that my
favorite part of that piece is there was
a part of that piece where they suggest
that Jordan Peterson is in favor of what
he called enforced monogamy yeah so they
enjoyed their suggestion was that Jordan
actually wants to shackle women to men
it's like you were dude like use Google
like it's it's an anthropological term
yeah it's talking about the difference
between biological monogamy and socially
constructed monogamy that's how he's
talking about yeah but the left is so
out to destroy him that they're willing
to take him out of context at any level
it's just nuts well he's also willing to
engage with people and discuss things
that he's talking to reporters that are
looking to get him and he's openly
discussing intellectual ideas and and
and and puzzles like how do you fix it I
don't know maybe it's enforcement aagama
like this is not this is like a weird
way of engaging with the press but he's
he's so comfortable with these idea
puzzles and and bouncing them around and
using them almost as intellectual
exercises that'll do it publicly with
someone who is looking for flaws in his
armor but this is what you do so well by
the way on your show and I was trying to
explain to somebody why your show is so
popular because it's its unique thing
what you do and what what I said to them
is that when I look at you as a host or
when I look at you as a thinker you're
somebody who's taking people along and
intellectual journey and you're taking
the journey with them it's like being on
a road trip of ideas with you on your
show do you think that's a pretty good
description of what you do it's what I
try for in a way just I want to know how
they think
it enriches the way I think when I have
smart people on and I go through their
thought process I feel like I get a
little rub from that I
I understand the way they're viewing the
world with their completely different
life than me I think there's there's a
great value in that and I think that's
one of the things that people get out of
the podcast is they're getting the same
thing that I'm getting well while I'm
sitting there talking to these people to
these people
so what so what's your big plan here
like you can continue what you're doing
obviously but where do you think you are
in in five years there's no plan there's
no plan to get here there's no plan to
stay
I have zero plan I mean I might abandon
it I don't know I might I might decide
people are too crazy it's difficult I
really don't know golf hunting in the
wilderness yeah I'll probably just just
just get a shack somewhere and just bow
hunt I don't know I really have no idea
where where it's going to go but I am
enjoying the fact that because the
podcast is popular I can get really
interesting people on like Howard Bloom
or Jordan Peterson or you or all these
fascinating people and have these great
conversations and I've really enjoyed
conversations it's taught me a lot about
the the way to communicate with people
allowing people to talk actually
listening to what they're saying
engaging them on their ideas not just
waiting for my time to talk which is
what so many people do I mean it's it's
also led me led me to understand how
rudimentary most people's conversation
skills are when I'm watching people even
in like really important meetings just
talk over each other and disregard with
each other they're saying there's no
like there's a lack of like solid
communication skills that I think you
really foster on a podcast and these
these conversations that we have I think
one of the best things about them is
that you're getting an insight and to
how other people think and it allows you
to examine the way you think and you by
just by virtue of listening to this
person through your headphones or in
your car you're comparing your thought
process to their thought process and I
think ultimately that's what we're
trying to strengthen the way we view the
world and and and strengthen our clarity
and and take in as much information as
we can and see that information for what
it truly is not what he what we
want it to be so in that journey what
you're doing in you have a very wide
variety of guess I know I've gotten
flack for a lot of the guests that
you've gotten on various sides including
flack for having me on your show how do
you how do you perform the gatekeeper
function how do you decide who is just
not worth having on your show or is
there anybody who you think is just not
worth having on your show I just I like
talking to people you know I mean if I
want to talk to someone I want to have
on my show I'm gonna like I told you I'm
gonna have Ted Nugent on my show that's
probably gonna be the most pushback
other than Alex Jones if anybody that
I've ever had but I don't think it's my
job to not talk to people that I want to
talk to I think it's my job to even if
someone's if I want it I mean there's
got to be some horrible people out there
that I would never want to talk to that
I just don't like the way they speak I
don't I don't like what they stand for
and maybe Ted's one of them I don't know
I have to sit down and talk to him but
as long as I feel that I'm interested in
having a conversation with that person
I'll air it and look there's a lot of
them out there I mean I do three hour
podcast and I do four or five a week you
don't like one of them good don't listen
to that one I mean I have ones on with
MMA fighters and I'll get like people
are gone
I hate those ones so well I said okay
let me just take those and I'll have a
separate podcast I'll label them the MMA
show the JRE MMA show so now you know
you know if I have cat Zingano on or
George st. Pierre we're going to talk
about fighting for a lot of the time and
then if I have on Jordan Peterson or Sam
Harris or whoever else I might be
interviewing Robert Schoch are you we're
gonna talk about different things and
you know you can like it or you don't
like it but there's plenty of people
that like it so I don't care you know
your again you have that fu money say
you're in good shape some tears I think
just but having that the the wherewithal
to understand that if you're enjoying it
if you like what you're doing that's
contagious you know these conversations
interesting conversations are contagious
like I am interested in people that are
engaged in interesting conversations and
when I listen to podcasts and I listen
to people discussing things and I know
that they're really locked into this
conversation it's fascinating to me I
mean and we don't get enough of that in
this world we are dealing with you know
you're in offices you're in cubicles
you're dealing with human resources and
there
demands on the the type of things you
can discuss and what you can get in
trouble for and most people for at least
eight hours out of their day they are
locked down with this rigid conformed
way of communicating and speaking and
it's very frustrating it's very
frustrating and it doesn't represent
your thoughts it represents these
patterns that you're expected to follow
in the world of business and and
commerce and you know office space you
know of politics and I just think it's
very very frustrating for people and
it's not natural and I think that's one
of the reasons why people yearn for
uncensored conversations well I mean
that's what you're gonna get if you go
to the Joe Rogan experience and it's it
is amazing if you haven't listened to it
first of all if you listen to this I'm
sure you've listened to Joe show but if
you haven't go check it out it's the Joe
Rogan experience Joe thanks so much for
stopping by
[Music]
the venture Pierrot shows Sunday special
is produced by Jonathan hey executive
producer Jeremy borin associate
producers Mathis Glover and Austin
Stevens edited by Alex singhara audio is
mixed by Mike Carmina hair and makeup is
by Jess wah alvera and title graphics by
Cynthia and Gullu the Ben Shapiro shows
Sunday special is a daily wire for word
publishing production copyright Ford
publishing 2018
[Music]